today i'm in colorado
a state that can see more snow than
alaska
standing here in the banks of this
frozen reservoir it's easy to understand
why water seems like a limitless
resource
but the fact is in the united states we
could face a national water shortage
in a little more than 50 years
[Music]
colorado needs to save every drop it
gets and colorado college which has been
ranked first for water conservation
among 280 colleges and universities is
leading the way
our water largely comes from the other
side of the continental divide we're
bringing it
through tunnels that are miles long
through the mountains into reservoirs
and then either into rivers or pipelines
that's something that a lot of our
students have never actually thought
about before
so how are you managing water here
we've reduced water usage by 38 percent
which is a pretty big drop i think it's
the biggest in the in the country
actually
multiple different ways the fixtures low
flow shower heads and in our residence
halls and
toilets things that aren't shiny flashy
exciting things
but you know as as we add all of those
together they start to have a really big
impact
and then just efficiencies you know
there's there's a lot of technical
projects
um that we've done one of the projects
that saved a lot of water
is the cooling system for our central
heating plant
we closed the loop on that that saved us
about three million gallons of water a
year
[Music]
there are many lessons we can learn from
colorado college i'm here in the
college's eco-home with a family of
students
who are learning more about being water
wise
talk to me a little bit about synergy
your relationship to water
here at synergy we do use gray water
when we shower we have like a five
gallon bucket below us that we
kind of just let fill up while we're
showering and then we use that to like
flush the toilet
so about half of our indoor water use is
spent in bathrooms with showers as the
major drain
on average american families use more
than 300 gallons of water every day
[Laughter]
and many of us still rinse our dirty
dishes under a running faucet before
loading them into the dishwasher
this is a huge waste of water because
you actually need the dishes to be dirty
as the enzymes and the detergent latch
onto food particles to work effectively
and it's these actions that could help
avert america's looming water crisis
giving the next generation a better
chance of never having to see
a water shortage